[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing a handful of Harry
Potter book characters who are nothing
like their movie
counterparts as a general rule fans of
book series know to watch movie
adaptations of the novels they love
without expecting too much for it is
extremely rare that a filmmaker's vision
will match the fictitious world that a
fan has created in their own mind after
all how could you expect every single
person to interpret a book the exact
same way from the appearance of the
characters to how the world looks around
them and even if there was some sort of
consensus on how a character was
supposed to look there's also the fact
that it's incredibly unlikely for there
to be an actor or actress out there who
perfectly resembles that character at
the right age has the correct dialect
and can act of course this seems even
more impossible when applying the
concept to an entire cast of characters
like in Harry Potter and so when the
first movie adaptation of the Harry
Potter series the philosopher stone was
released in 2001 it goes without saying
that fans of the books knew things
wouldn't be perfect but it wasn't
unreasonable to think that the films
would at least try to accurately reflect
the people and places that fans had read
on the pages of the first few books and
in many ways it did especially that
first film however as more and more
movies were made there were some pretty
glaring differences between the books
and the films in particular with some of
the main characters of the series and so
here are five book characters that I
think are nothing like their movie
counterparts one minione Granger ma the
infamous miss Noah at least in the books
from her first introduction in the
philos pher Stone and Beyond herione
Granger is described in the novels as a
somewhat nosy rather bossy young witch
who let's be clear is not an immediate
friend of Harry's she is incredibly well
read and has a lot of initiative having
read much of the reading material ahead
of the start of the school year she also
has wildly frizzy brown hair and overly
large front teeth she is not meant to be
that traditionally attractive of course
over the years she becomes more
tolerable and lovable in the case of Ron
especially in the way that she shares
her knowledge however a lot of her
personality traits and just about all of
her physical traits with the exception
of her large teeth remain the same in
the movies however both Hermione's
appearance and personality are
completely different while the actress
who portrayed her Emma Watson was the
correct age and had brown hair that was
where the similarities stopped Emma's
hair is Not By Nature frizzy and so for
the first movie it was teased out to be
bushier than normal but but as the
movies progressed Emma's hair got
flatter and smoother and by the end of
the films she basically just had wavy
hair Emma saione also never had the
large teeth however we can hardly fault
the actress for this especially
considering that she did try to wear
fake teeth to incorporate this feature
but as a young actor found it too
difficult to speak her lines with them
in in terms of the movie H's personality
she does start off somewhat similar to
her novel counterpart although she's
given a few other character's lines
along the way more on that in just a
moment however as with her looks movie
Herman's characteristics drastically
change over the course of the movies and
she does little to developmentally
mature instead she simply becomes an
overly perfect witch in just about every
way two Ron Weasley if you've never read
the Harry Potter books and are only a
fan of the movies then you likely think
of Ron Weasley as a bit of a goof who's
really afraid of spiders but anyone
who's read even one of the novels knows
that Ron Weasley at least in book form
is so much more than that for starters
being the only one of the golden Trio
who grew up in Wizarding family Ron is
constantly educating both Harry and
Hermione yes herione on the ways of The
Wizarding World in fact in the books Ron
is portrayed as quite intelligent and
quick-witted he often receives similar
grades to Harry and is equally as able
to perform the types of spells and Magic
as the boy who lived compare this to the
clumsy o version of Ron in the films who
can barely cast his Patronis and whose
intelligent lines were almost entirely
given to the character of herione again
and again in the books Ron is also
incredibly Brave which is certainly not
how he's portrayed in the films there
are a number of examples of him standing
up for and protecting Harry and other
characters throughout the novels whereas
in the movies some of his most
courageous moments are once again given
to other characters film Ron played by
Rupert Grint is also not all that
similar in app to book Ron despite the
red hair in fact I'd argue that the
ginger hair is the only thing the two
have in common in the books Ron is
described as tall long and lanky with
bright red hair and freckles Rupert
Grint is not particularly tall long nor
lanky and he certainly doesn't have
freckles three jinny Weasley while in
appearance actress Bonnie Wright's
portrayal of jinny Weasley was spot on
there is so much that is different
between book and movie Jenny
particularly in terms of her personality
this of course is no fault of Bonnie
wries but rather due to the exclusion of
certain storylines from the films in the
novels jinny becomes a real powerhouse
of a young witch she speaks her mind she
stands up for herself and others she's
an exceptional quidditch player and
she's talented with her magic bat
Bogey's hex ring a bell anyone sadly due
to not enough Screen Time jinny's
character was never really fully
realized in the films instead she came
across as quiet and demure yes she still
played on the Gryffindor Quidditch team
and was part of Dumbledore's Army but
fans never really got to see her true
bad our self in the movies four
Bellatrix of strange despite returning
from her stint in aaban more gaunt than
she'd been before the Bellatrix of
strange of the books is described as a
witch who is classically beautiful with
an air of arrogance to her beauty she is
tall with dark heavy lied eyes a strong
jaw and long black hair as a loyal Death
Eater batric spent time in prison rather
than renounce her Devotion to Voldemort
and throughout the book she's willing to
do dark and terrible things in the name
of serving the dark lord and while much
of this is well adapted to the movie
version of Bellatrix there are some
glaring differences which make the two
characters extremely different from one
another for starters while book
Bellatrix is clearly a psychopath she's
also quite put together throughout the
novels we witness her tactfully
manipulate those around her and use her
intelligence to her advantage in the
movies however she's more more of a
caricature of Bellatrix than anything
actress Helena balham Carter does a
marvelous job making her Bellatrix a
straightup basket case but this
depiction of her is rather unlike the
complex dark witch who Graces the pages
of the books five seus Snape where to
start with seus Snape while there are a
few similarities between book Snape and
movie Snape the most glaring
dissimilarity between the two versions
of this character is definitely their
age at the beginning of the novel series
Professor Snape is meant to be in his
early 30s but because the filmmakers
wanted Alan Rickman for the part which I
totally get don't get me wrong movie
Snape ended up being closer to 40 this
resulted in the film adaptation of Snape
being somewhat more mature than his book
counterpart which dramatically affected
several of his personality traits for
example in the books Snape is fairly
spiteful snarky and Petty and his
hatefulness towards Harry rarely feels
Justified whereas in the movies he comes
across as simply dark and a little
ominous and a lot more likable movie
Snape also has many more moments of
comic relief which seems to lend to his
likability and although alen Rickman
Snape had shoulder length black hair I'd
argue that his appearance wasn't that
accurate of a depiction of book Snape
who is described as thin with greasy
black hair and a large hooked nose and
with that we've come to the end of
today's video what did you think did I
miss anything please share your thoughts
in the comments below and as always if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
like it and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to
[Music]
live